[Música]
apenas se conocieron los resultados de
las presidenciales dónde manuel macro no
fue reelecto en francia para otros cinco
años más de gobierno ya ese país gira su
mirada hacia las legislativas el del 12
y 19 de junio durante el próximo
quinquenio macrón deberá gestionar una
política de equilibrios para poder
gobernar entre la ultraderecha liderado
por marine lepén que obtuvo el mejor
resultado de su historia y una izquierda
sólida de la mano de jean luc mélenchon
quien tras las parlamentarias espera ser
el primer ministro de francia para ello
para analizar entonces lo que ocurrió
tras estas elecciones presidenciales de
segunda vuelta saludamos a nuestro
primer invitado del día el es pascal
drogba analista político y especialista
en relaciones internacionales gracias
pascal por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de francés de cuatro en nuestra
mesa de trabajo también nos acompaña
nuestra compañera rosa pérez más seguros
a bienvenida muy buen día iniciamos una
semana más entonces analizando lo que
ocurrió ayer en francia rosa buenos días
raúl y buenos dias pascal queríamos
empezar preguntándoles para ver si nos
puede hacer una lectura general de estos
resultados antes de entrar a desgranar
en detalle las distintas aristas de las
elecciones de ayer
bueno con rózsa diría antes de todo qué
es una victoria para él manuel marcó
definitivamente pues obtuvo 58 por
ciento 54 4
imagine los 40 y
1.46 es decir que ha sido una victoria
una victoria electoral pero a la vez en
un contexto en el cual los desafíos son
grandes y les recordaron desafíos en el
término del frente interior en francia-
desafíos para garantizar la unión de un
país cuya parte de la población tiene el
sentimiento de una forma de
fragmentación explicando votos que pudo
haber el sabor de la izquierda radical
de mel antxon o de asia ma jin depende
pero también un frente y lo recortó bien
con el contexto europeo de voluntarismo
voluntarismo sobre varios frentes
a nivel a nivel europeo en materia de
independencia de europa para también que
francia sea un motor de ese nuevo
dinamismo europeo pero también un
dinamismo un voluntarismo interno y lo
vimos con la orientación ecológica sobre
la cual eran el mejor
quiso dar un impulso durante los últimos
días de su campaña claro pascal como
macro entonces puede hacer esta unidad
en un país como usted lo dijo bien
fragmentada más evidenció tras estas
elecciones
presidenciales y que se va a evidenciar
aún más en estas legislativas de junio
pero ya hablamos de esas legislativas
más adelante cómo lograr macrón esta
unidad que incluso él sabe que la tiene
por delante porque dijo que no va a ser
una continuidad su mandato sino
prácticamente un nuevo gobierno de
unidad del presidente de makro entonces
ya sabe lo que tiene por delante cómo
lograrlo
si lo tiene clarísimo es por eso que
hablo de voluntarismo pero ayer lo dijo
ya no es el candidato de un campo contra
otro campo es el presidente de todos con
sus palabras el presidente entonces eso
quiere decir reinventar reconstruir una
unión nación tal francia ha cambiado en
estos 20 últimos años y por cierto uno
por unos han podido tener ese
sentimiento de una forma de comunicación
de aislamiento social mientras otra
parte de la población pues y de los
activos tuvieron a tirar aquí puede
hacer más internacional o más global es
decir pues unir unir supone bases la
primera bases es garantizar esa
transición económica una economía más
verde una economía competitiva atractiva
lo que supone puesto
una forma de transición con todo con
todos esos supone también un apoyo a los
salariados tanto como un sistema de
jubilación pues que ha sido central en
la campaña en el aspecto social un
sistema de jubilación viable sostenible
financiado y es la razón por la cual
hizo pues que se pueda porque la edad de
salida legal no decía los 65 años de
manera gradual unión unión en el
interior unión también pues en lewis
exterior no olvidemos que hoy en día
europa tiene un conflicto sobre su
subsuelo el conflicto ucraniano pero
también pues francia es un miembro
permanente del consejo de seguridad de
naciones unidas es una potencia nuclear
nuclear civil que también es un elemento
que subraye orden el mango para reforzar
esa independencia energética pero
también una potencia nuclear
militar sobre todos los océanos toda la
parte del planeta ya que francia tiene
la segunda superficie marítima del mundo
después de eeuu más de 11 millones de
kilómetros cuadrados es decir que eso
supone el sentido de una responsabilidad
responsabilidad histórica hoy en día y
lo lo mencionaron perfectamente bien
pues diciendo que hay muchas preguntas
en la sociedad hoy en día pero también
una responsabilidad hacia el futuro si
vas a inventar esa unión nacional y
particularmente en termine esta unión
nacional en relación con las personas de
izquierdas a las que ayer macrón no
directamente pero reconoció haberle
apoyado para frenar a la extrema derecha
como se podría traducir este
agradecimiento y esta deuda que ayer
emanuel macrón acabó reconociendo con
este electorado si además rosa yo quiero
completar ahí también hay ese coqueteo
que hizo macro con los ecologistas usted
también lo mencionaba muy bien en este
contexto de la guerra en ucrania pues
todo pareciera que se pudiera digamos
acelerar esta transición a las energías
verdes pero no lo están haciendo así
digamos que los países en vez de
acelerar esta transición
mack macrón también abanderando este
este paso a estas energías limpias
extranjeras ya verdes pues no lo está
haciendo de esa manera porque están
volcándose a nuevas energías fósiles por
otro lado porque también esto
bueno primero el
recuerda la importancia de la energía
nuclear su segundo
cuando se dice que se debe poner más
verde la economía eso supone el aparato
productivo el aparato productivo
nacional con esa voluntad de atraer de
nuevo el aparato en el mismo suelo
nacional
eso es un ángulo bastante importante es
también puedes desarrollar todo un plan
de apoyo para que se logre esa mutación
del aparato productivo de todas las
estructuras tanto como del papel
obviamente de salariado en esa esa
producción y que esa producción pues sea
tatis pueda satisfacer el mercado
nacional tanto como puede ser un
elemento de exportación
y pascal
precisamente esta deuda con la izquierda
que le mencionábamos cómo puede
traducirse de cara a las legislativas
ahora que ella la izquierda y
precisamente el líder de la francia
insumisión lumen ansón ya ha conseguido
este bloqueo a la extrema derecha ahora
este llamado a esta tercera vuelta ya
tener mayoría en la asamblea nacional es
posible puede dejar un look melanson
como pide ser finalmente escogido por
emanuel macrón como primer ministro
para las instituciones en francia no
funcionan así el primer ministro es el
jefe del gobierno es el ejercicio de la
mayoría mayoría parlamentaria
aquí está rosa haciendo referencia y lo
hace muy bien haciendo referencia a una
declaración del líder de la izquierda
radical francesa son melón son que dijo
cuesta no eligen el primer ministro en
francia no se elige el primer ministro
el primer ministro está nombrado por el
jefe de estado quien él está elegido y
lo acabamos de ver al sufragio universal
directo primero pascal precisamente de
ávila pregunta si los mataron disculpe
sin macrón se puede ver obligado a
elegir a me lanzan como primer ministro
esa era la pregunta si me la acción fue
conceder una amplia mayoría sí sí sí sí
sí yo sé que era la pregunta y eso ya
recibimos un hombre si la izquierda
radical tiene una mayoría de diputados a
la asamblea nacional en junio la mayoría
sobre una asamblea de 577 diputados es
de 289 entonces sí temeroso tiene por lo
es el primer grupo
la primera fracción en la próxima
asamblea nacional y por supuesto es el
líder de la futura mayoría pues el
presidente de república nombrada el
líder y sería en este caso el pero no
estamos para nada hoy en viena y sea en
ese esquema se va a empezar la campaña
de las legislativas
el año el marco va a apoyar obviamente
sobre aliados y sobre sus apoyos para
explicar seguir explicando el programa
sobre el cual él ha sido elegido y
llamando los franceses en darle una
mayoría para que pueda ser llevar a cabo
el programa sobre el cual acaba de ser
reelegida pascal también estas
elecciones evidenciaron dos cosas la
primera la abstención la apatía de los
franceses y la segunda como quedaron los
partidos tradicionales la caída de las
formaciones como los republicanos y los
socialistas también como se puede leer
todo esto
sí pues tienes toda la razón primero la
abstención siempre hay personas que no
quieren participar del debate nacional
dónde se sienten interesados hay podemos
imaginar también pues que después de
esos años pero que tuvimos en francia
tanto como en el mundo tanto como en
américa latina dos años de pandemia de
parálisis de etcétera o que una gente se
hizo apartar o estará en cólera y no
quería participar 28 de abstención
puntos de abstención si eso todo puede
ser segundo si es cierto que el partido
socialista y el partido de ser
republicanos dos partidos tradicionales
que participaron del gobierno
en esos últimos diseños ya están por
desaparecer y por menos la candidata del
partido socialista realizó apenas 1.8
por ciento la del partido republicanos
4.8 es decir que definitivamente al
nivel nacional esos partidos están por
desaparecer que significa significa pues
que estamos cambiando de época
y obviamente pues que nos supieron pegar
a la necesidad de la población en una
guerra a donde las cosas van más
seguidamente estamos a la guerra digital
numérica y también pues una guerra es
más violenta eso no te quiera vivir nos
que reconocer donde las cosas son más
más claras violenta hacia la cuales hay
que contestar de manera rápida fue la
que hizo envenena